the baby  starts  has space  and as it comes into the world  it picks up  its identity  except the Assumption of  separation  of location  of lack  and all the conditions  that then makes it  feel unhole  dissatisfied  and makes it seek  at first  substances  experiences  relationships  and as it  finds  entheogens  meditation  self-inquiry  it slowly begins dissolving  the assumptions  of separation  of  lack  of of location  and it returns to the primordial source  that gave rise to it  from there occasionally  the sense of self  can jut out a little bit  and then it'll relax  and shut out a little bit  relax  and this is what's called  purification  the Alchemy  the deep conditioning  and that is how to use  child's toy  to understand  the nature  of reality